but every building is destroy at some  point the whole city yeah  I love what they are  [Music]  [Music]  so we're here right now the city of  Karkos  it was only recently taken for Isis it's  mostly cleared we're hearing there's  still some IEDs and then at night there  are still attacks City itself is  completely destroyed we're gonna go  around with the NPA which is sort of  Christian militia that formed over here  and they're gonna guide us we missed it  where are we right now move out of my  house and never be here my house is gone  cheers l'homme as I told you on the  first guest my house  thank you for having yeah we go they  stole my head condition area clear or  not these guys aren't acting like it is  [Music]  I hope my body or my still here so I'm  giving him as a guest with the apartment  [Music]  let's go the door what's wrong